hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section 5 of
his inquiry concerning human
understanding David Hume is going to
discuss the nature of belief what is it
when we believe something to be the case
or we believe in something for example
that if I were to tighten this tie
yet further then it would begin to choke
me you know that I don't have to really
think it through in order to say yeah
yeah that's that's right
so he's going to tell us that from a
philosophical point of view we can't
really go that far with this but we we
all know what it is to believe in
something we can't define belief but we
can at least describe it and in the
description that he provides he's going
to give us some of the tools for making
sense out of what it is and we should
begin by noting something that you could
say starts the section on belief and
then ends the section that's
specifically about belief namely that
belief is produced by an object present
to the senses or memory something right
and then some principle of Association
the one that he talks about the most
there is what we typically call constant
conjunction in that section here's taken
about customary conjunction because he's
just finished talking about the
importance of customer habit in allowing
us to have beliefs about empirical
matters matters of fact or truths of
existence as he calls it but there's two
other modes of Association or principles
of Association that play a really
central role in David Humes work and
that is resemblance and when he calls
contiguity which means being you know
sort of connected together in space and
time so we have resemblance contiguity
and cause and effect cause and effect
being understood under analysis by Hume
as constant or customary conjunction of
two things together or classes of things
together so that said coming back to
this right we have some sort of object
that is either present to us in sensory
experience or perhaps inside of
ourselves don't like we feel a passion
or it's something that we're remembering
or calling to mind and then we believe
in something else as a result of that
now he tells us that one way to
understand this is by carrying out a
kind of contrast a comparison between
two things and this is how he begins
part two of section five he says nothing
is more free than our imagination
although it cannot exceed that original
stock of ideas furnished by the internal
and external senses it has an unlimited
power of mixing compounding separating
dividing these ideas in all the
varieties of fiction and vision it can
feign a train of events with the
appearance of reality ascribed to them a
particular time and place
conceived of them is existent and paint
them out to itself with every
circumstance that belongs to any
historical fact which it believes with
the greatest certainty so you know let's
pause on that for just a second and
think about what he's saying there and
we'll do an exercise that will call upon
your capacity to use your imagination in
that way so imagine and this this will
not be as easy for some of you as it
will for others and
imagine that you're within a pine forest
now you may have never been in a pine
forest in your life at all so you might
have to picture it from images that
you've seen somewhere or movie clips or
documentaries or something like that and
I'll describe it a little bit to you so
there are these massive pine trees that
stick up and they have branches coming
out with with green needles on them and
as you're walking along the needles that
have been shed are on the forest floor
so it's very quiet as a matter of fact
the entire Pine Grove there's not much
wind it's very quiet you might be able
to hear some animal noises or the
rustling of leaves elsewhere maybe
traffic noises from somewhere else
but it's it's a quieter place when you
enter it then the outside is and as you
walk along your footsteps hardly make
any sound because they're muffled by the
needles and you can smell the almost
intoxicating odor of pine all over the
place now you might have to imagine this
from your experiences of smelling
something that's scented with pine if
you've never actually been in a pine
forest what have you been doing this
entire time you've been imagining you've
been taking these little bits of stuff
and combining them together into
something that's like an experience but
it's not an experience it's something
you've as we say visualized although
visualisation is only part of it you're
also imagining sound and smell and
perhaps even tactile sensations as well
that is something that human would say
is a fancy or you know a fiction we've
just engaged in it right now you don't
actually believe that you're at a pine
forest were you to do that you would
probably either have like gone super
deep into some sort of you know
imaginary experience that you now think
is real or you would be crazy if you're
taking the the imaginations as being
completely real so he goes on and he
says what's the difference between such
a fiction and a belief what is it he
says it's not in any peculiar idea which
is the next
such a conception as commands our assent
there's no difference in content right
you could in fact be in the pine forest
as a matter of fact as I talk about it I
feel things because I love pine forests
having grown up in an area that included
many of them and having all sorts of
good associations with camping and stuff
like that it can can it you know I'm
thinking maybe I'd like to go later on
today and go to a pine forest hey for
you it's probably not having that
association so he says it's not an any
particular idea that that's a component
of it so what is it he says the mind has
authority over all its ideas it could
voluntarily annex this particular idea
it's any fiction and consequently be
able to believe whatever it pleases
contrary to what we find by daily
experience but that's not the case we
can in our conception during the head of
a man to a body of a horse but it's not
in our power to believe that such an
animal has ever really existed we can
imagine anything we like think about
dungeons and dragons and the old Monster
Manual if you've ever seen that sort of
thing or any role-playing game right any
computer game can think about Minecraft
and creepers those are imaginary and you
can you know make the graphics really
great and stick them on with virtual
reality goggles and I suppose put out a
suit that like buff at you and the thing
is punching here or something like that
but it's it's still not real you don't
have what humans calling belief at this
point because if belief was just like a
component of an idea where you could add
it in
so what what is you know he says that
belief is says the difference between
fiction and belief lies in some
sentiment or feeling which is a next to
the latter the next to believe belongs
to belief not to the former and depends
not on the will nor can be demanded by
pleasure or at pleasure rather so what
does it mean well we we use our will
when we direct our imagination hey think
about this think about this we're doing
so just at pleasure when we're letting
our mind wander and our
is coming up with daydreams like oh
wouldn't it be cool if I won the lottery
and I'd buy myself this this wonderful
boat and I'd camp out along the
Mississippi River like we did when I was
a kid you know whatever it is you're
imagining right
you could come up with all sorts of
other things many of them quite quite a
pleasant to indulge in but we don't
believe in any of them
as soon as somebody says hey what you're
thinking about you're like oh I was
thinking about this thing that's really
just a fiction and not reality this is
why some people would actually prefer to
stay in their daydreams because they
think their life sucks the things that
they believe in aren't any fun so we've
got a sentiment or feeling right that
plays a role in belief he says it must
be excited by nature like other
sentiments and it must rise from the
particular situation in which the mind
is placed at any particular juncture so
whenever any object is presented to the
memory or senses it immediately by the
force of custom carries the imagination
to conceive that object which is usually
conjoined to it and then we get this
this feeling or sentiment different from
those as he says from the loose reveries
of the fancy daydreaming again right so
he says this is this is what the whole
of belief is there's no matter of fact
that we believe so firmly that we can't
conceive the contrary there would be no
difference between the conception
assented to and that which rejected if
it were not for some sentiment which
distinguishes the one from the other
this is the example of a billiard ball
so playing pool as we call it here so
you know you hit the ball the cue ball
with the stick it rolls it's going to
hit the other billiard ball and it's
going to knock it into the pocket and
then you're going to continue the game
right you believe even though it could
go differently that when you hit the
ball that ball is going to roll and it's
going to transmit that energy to the
other ball which is going to go in that
direction if it doesn't do that you're
like oh man I shot bad I can't
miscalculated the angle or you know
maybe the the the table itself is warped
or there's something wrong with these
balls right you don't you don't you
don't question your belief that this is
what should have happened instead
you start looking for other factors why
because you actually believe and he goes
on and he says we cannot define this
sentiment were we to try to attempt it
and you can bet that Hume has attempted
it he says we would find it too
difficult if not impossible task why in
the same manner as if we should
endeavour to to find the feeling of cold
or the passion of anger to a creature
who has never had any experience of
these sentiments I mean you either you
either know what cold is like or you
don't you either know what anger is like
or you don't if some other creature is
like what does this anger thing of which
you speak you'd be like well you know
it's like when you get mad and they
watch getting mad well it's like when
you get angry that's not helpful at all
you can't define it you can however
describe it he says and so here's the
description that he provides he says I
say belief is nothing but a more vivid
lively forceable firm steady conception
of an object than what the imagination
alone is ever able to attain so we've
got really two important components to
this characterization right we have a
bunch of qualities that are being
ascribed to it that hopefully we
understand and then are supposed to
apply to something that's essentially
cognitive right but also feeling
effective and then we have a contrast
with what a fancy or a fiction or pure
imagination is able to be so let's look
at the first part right
lively vivid those are two synonyms for
the same thing basically forceable firm
steady that's also helpful as well it's
it's something that impresses itself
upon us more you might think back to the
first part of this where he defined the
difference between ideas and impressions
in very similar terms right and we don't
go any any further than that with with
Hume so he says this variety of terms
which may seem so on unfill Asafa chol
is intended only
to express that act to the mind which
renders realities or what is taken for
such we can have belief in things that
are not realities more present to us
than fictions causes them to weigh more
in the thought gives them a superior
influence on the passions and
imagination he goes on a little bit
further and and gives us some further
some some additional characterizations
about this saying that the belief is
something felt by the mind which
distinguishes the ideas of the judgment
from the fictions of the imagination it
gives them the ideas of the judgment
more weight and influence makes them
appear of greater importance and forces
them in the mind and renders them the
governing principle of our action and he
gives us an example here so this is
quite helpful I here at present for
instance a person's voice with whom I am
acquainted and the sound comes as from
the next room so I'm hearing somebody
maybe from a speaker or something like
that the impression of my senses
immediately conveys my thought to the
person together with all the surrounding
objects I paint them out to myself as
existing at present with the same
qualities and Relations of which I
formerly knew them possessed these take
faster hold of my mind than ideas of a
fiction like an enchanted castle these
are very different from the feeling and
of a greater influence of every kind
either to give pleasure or pain joy or
sorrow and so he goes on and he ends
this by saying where we started the
sentiment of belief is nothing but a
conception more intense and steady than
one attends the mere fictions of the
imagination and that this manner of
conception arises from a customary
conjunction of the object with something
present to the memory or senses but he's
going to go on and talk about the two
other modes or principles of Association
of ideas in our mind and those can help
us produce belief as well that is
resemblance and contiguity although
these are usually going to also involve
some cause and effect or
constant conjunction
you